[Music]
panama is one of the wettest countries
on earth
so how can a panama canal be running out
of
[Music]
water in parts of panama it rains over
200 days a year
but in recent years the country has also
experienced unprecedented drought
what we're experiencing in panama is
exactly the sort of thing that many
global climate change models have been
predicting and that's an increase in
extreme events in the 140 years that the
panama canal authority has been
measuring rainfall
in the last 21 years we've seen eight of
the 10 greatest storms
but at the same time we've had the three
year on year driest years ever so we're
seeing this
real increase in extreme events that
simply we've never seen
that's a problem for a number of reasons
one of them is that an estimated 40
percent of panama's economic activity
relies on money brought in from the
panama canal and the panama now needs
water to function
lots of water
the panama canal works with fresh water
so rainfall for us is very important
and water storage for that matter the
canal links the pacific ocean to the
atlantic ocean and functions as a kind
of water elevator ships enter a series
of chambers and at each step the chamber
gets pumped full of millions of gallons
of water that lift the vessels into the
next chamber
when unprecedented droughts hit the
canal was forced to restrict what's
known as the draft the depth at which
ships sit as they cross the waterway the
more cargo a ship carries the greater
draft it needs meaning some ships
weren't able to pass through fully
loaded
water was so abundant that it was not on
top of mind until recent years when we
saw the the changes of the rainfall
patterns we had drier years closer so
that forced us to
to think differently
you know when scarcity is the
the mother of invention in 2016 elia
oversaw the canal's biggest expansion
yet and built new water-saving basins
for storage but there weren't enough to
make up for declining water supplies
this is a daily thing you know we
monitor the lake levels daily we monitor
the rainfall daily we put together a
plant for the next two weeks how much
water do we need to save but the canal
is not the only issue the main sources
of water that supply the canal also
supply half a panama's population with
drinking water the challenge that the
panama canal authority has is to provide
enough water for its business and at the
same time provide sufficient drinking
water for the million plus people who
depend on the panama canal watershed for
the drinking water both in terms of not
having too much because that would be
a disaster for the system if we had too
much and overflow the dam but at the
same time you also have to protect
against having too little water so
there's this very delicate
balancing act that they have to have
already access to drinking water is a
challenge across panama particularly in
mountainous areas where infrastructure
is lacking de la cinco
[Music]
[Music]
herrera lives in the community of cerro
penang about 40 minutes from panama city
the area's 5 000 inhabitants have been
without continuous access to drinking
water since the 90s
[Music]
the community used to be serviced by an
aqueduct but in 2005 a private owner
sold the land it was built on to
purchase drinking water bottle must now
drive to the closest town
while these particular water shortages
are tied to a lack of infrastructure and
not directly caused by the canal's
activities the paradox of particular
situation is that cerro pagnon has lots
of water water that feeds the panama
canal the rainwater which drains off its
hillsides feeds the cartoon reservoir
which provides water to the canal and
bartelo and his community make sure the
area is forested so the watershed
remains stable
[Music]
so how does panama solve its water
problem both for the canal and its
people the canal authorities are
pursuing a two-pronged approach
the first is to develop better storage
options precisely to be able to store
some of that water that eventually goes
into the ocean if we have no storage
capacity we need to spill the second is
to find new sources of water mariota and
her team are seeking bidders for a two
billion dollar project looking to do
exactly that the project is likely to
combine approaches like reusing
wastewater and perhaps desalination we
make sure we balance that all the needs
are met while we finish our new water
projects that will be able to kind of
give us that
assurance that we will have enough water
for the future years the future will be
more relaxed more like before but it's a
delicate process in a sense that we need
to be very aware of it and we monitor
all the time it's implemented buscams
[Music]
b
[Music]
you